mein thema heute abend uns fehlen
hunderttausende handwerker als
handwerksmeister tochter für mich eine
sehr erschreckende zahl bei den
arbeitsagenturen sind 150.000 offene
stellen gelistet da nicht alle betriebe
überhaupt ihre vakanzen melden geht der
zentralverband des deutschen handwerks
von schätzungsweise rund
250.000 vielen handwerkern aus tendenz
steigend wir müssen bei der nachwuchs
und fachkräfte versorgung
schnellstmöglich entgegensteuern ich bin
mir sicher sonst droht uns ein verlust
von wertschöpfung und wohlstand meine
erste frage geht heute als frau bauer
wollte nämlich wissen ob der
fachkräftemangel im handwerk noch ohne
einwanderung zu schaffen ist ich würde
sagen es kann nur mit einwanderung und
zwar mit fachkräfte einwanderung gehen
in unseren arbeitsmarkt und übrigens
nicht nur im bereich der handwerker
sondern auch im bereich der
arbeitskräfte fachkräfte im allgemeinen
es fehlt an allen ecken und enden muss
sehen sie auch an den flughäfen jetzt am
boden personal entsprechend akquiriert
wird aus der türkei um viel mehr ich
glaube es war auch ein modernes
einwanderungsgesetz in unseren
arbeitsmarkt es braucht aber auch
genauso die stärkung der beruflichen
bildung im bildungssystem sie haben
jetzt auch als fdp angestrebt dass die
amtssprache auch englisch die zweite
amtssprache wird was erhoffen sie sich
davon wir haben so viele menschen in
unserem lande nicht glaube einfach dass
es sich wohltuend ist für unser land
dass wir auch in englisch gerade in
behörden noch arbeiten das würde vieles
vereinfachen vieles an bürokratie auch
vereinfachen und insgesamt mit zweite
möglichkeit geben viele länder machen es
uns vor warum sollten wir nicht auch
diesen weg gehen vorbei wollen sie
mitgehen bei frau bauer dass wir
gezielte einwanderung brauchen um das
fachkräfte den fachkräftemangel
besonders im handwerk was mir sehr am
herzen liegt zu schaffen
ich kann ich kann ihre seite da völlig
verstehen möglich dass auch am herzen
ich habe mich viel mit handwerker kann
man unterhalten und die haben noch ein
weiteres problem aufgezeigt und zwar das
hauptproblem in deutschland ist dass die
studiengänge also einmal die akademische
ausbildung die universitäre ausbildung
und daneben die berufliche ausbildung
nicht gleichwertig vom staat behandelt
werden also als beispiel heißt das ein
philosophie student an der uni wird wird
viel stärker vom steuerzahler gefördert
als jetzt der maschinenschlosser in
ausbildung und teilweise ist es ja auch
noch so dass sie ihre studiengänge ihre
lehrgänge selbst bezahlen müssen also da
würde ich mir erstmal erhoffen dass wir
diese drei und sonnig ist nahe aber dass
die ausbildungswege einfach gleichwertig
auch behandelt werden das wäre schon mal
ein guter schritt die duale
berufsausbildung auch mit auszubauen
würden sie also den meister umsonst
machen der meister kostet heute geld bis
zu 10.000 euro man kann ihn auch in
teilzeit machen der meister kommt nach
der gesellen lehrer würden sie das zum
beispiel ansagen philosophie studenten
dürfen auch quasi umsonst studieren also
soll der meisterabschluss auch umsonst
zu erwerben sein ich bin grundsätzlich
für für gleichwertigkeit wenn es heute
so ist das der diplom kaufmann oder der
philosophie masterabschluss
irgendwie nichts kostet umsonst ist ein
semesterticket studienbeiträgen 180 euro
um die wahrheit die wahrheit ist ja es
ist ja nicht umsonst es gibt ja auch
kein free lunch das sind
steuerzahlergelder also wenn man nachher
von der ausbildung profitiert dann kann
man auch selbst teilweise die kosten
tragen was ich einfach sage ist dass die
studiengänge
gleichwertig behandelt werden müssen und
dieser ausbildungsweg des handwerkers
deutlich aufgewertet werden muss und das
ist gerade nicht der fall und deswegen
haben wir gerade diesen
fachkräfte-mangel vor allen dingen im
handwerk wir haben ja noch mehr glaube
ich dass das muss man mal sagen es gibt
es derzeit bundesweit 1,7 millionen
offene stellen ja und ich glaube das was
frau bauer gerade sagte mit der
zuwanderung wir werden gar nicht
drumherum kommen ob wir jetzt eine
gleichheit ein universitäten und dann im
handwerk haben die werden gar nicht
drumherum kommen um die einwanderung
denn wenn wir uns anschauen wie viele
menschen aus dem arbeitsmarkt in den
nächsten jahren in rente gehen bis 20 31
werden das jetzt ein data geben weil zu
wenig junge menschen unten in den
arbeitsmarkt nachwachsen an delta haben
nach schätzungen des instituts der
deutschen wirtschaft von 5 millionen
und das bedeutet am ende das wir wenn
wir unseren wohlstand einigermaßen
halten wollen um einwanderung gar nicht
drumherum kommen wir kommen nicht drum
herum bleibt statistiken die zahl würde
ich gerne noch einmal einwerfen braucht
die wirtschaft 500.000 einwanderer
jährlich gegen den fachkräftemangel wie
sehen sie das herr winkler ich wollte
sagen als als arbeiterklasse kind und
auch noch als
einwanderer kind habe ich das schon eine
dezidierte meinung und ein aspekt glaube
ich finde was haben ihre eltern gemacht
hätte sagt arbeiterklasse kind also
jetzt werden sie lachen mein vater ist
eigentlich opernsänger aber da er nicht
studiert hat und daher die mindestens
die hälfte der zeit seines lebens mit
handwerklichen dingen verbracht hat
erlaube ich mir dann doch zu sagen ich
bin arbeiterklasse kind
der punkt der mir noch ein bisschen
fehlt in der debatte ist die schule sie
haben ja die das studium angesprochen
man muss doch auch mal sagen rot grün
hat in den ländern systematisch in den
letzten jahrzehnten dieses diese
wunderbare idee des dreigliedrigen
schulsystems züchter die hauptschule ist
fast schon ein thema kommt später nach
hessen wissen wollen bleiben die einmal
bei der these die ich ja auch
mitgebracht habe heute abend wie sehen
sie das sie haben gesagt sie haben
selbst migrationshintergrund woher
kommen sie rumänien rumänien wir haben
jetzt hier die these dass die wirtschaft
vom 4000 einwanderer jährlich braucht
gegen den fachkräftemangel wie sehen sie
das wie würden sie sich deutschland als
einwanderungsland vorstellen ich glaube
wir sind schon auf halbem weg dahin ich
glaube dass
das wenn das so ist wir natürlich uns
dagegen nicht sperren können ich glaube
aber dass parallel zu der frage der
einwanderung immer auch die frage sein
muss wie können wir handwerk attraktiver
machen das war ausgangs und ich glaube
da kommen immer nur mit einwanderung
nicht weiter sondern wir müssen uns auch
fragen was diejenigen die schon bei uns
sind dass wir bei denen machen können
dass das handwerk attraktiver wird und
das beginnt leider in der schule und
dann bin ich leider wieder bei der
hauptschule die idee war doch wunderbar
wer mehr in eine handwerkliche richtung
geht mehr dort seine talente hat geht
auch die hauptschule wer mehr akademisch
orientierte es geht aufs gymnasium
keines davon ist schlechter als das
andere leider ist es wenn ist nicht mit
der einteilung ist schon so als wenn man
sagt derjenige der nicht so akademisch
ist der soll später handwerker werden er
geht auf die hauptschule derjenige der
akademische erst mal abitur ist
handwerker wenn man ehrlich ist dann
wenn man mal macht den gesellen man
macht den meister dann gründet man sein
eigenes unternehmen da würde ich schon
sagen das abitur auch gar nicht so
schlecht vorher also ist es überhaupt
gut dass so einzugliedern mit dem die
eine schulform ist für akademiker die
andere schulform was für handwerker oder
er nach talenten gehen wer die lange auf
welche schule geht auch da habe ich eine
klare meinung ich glaube dass das dass
die unterteilung sehr wichtig ist wir
kranken ja in einem system wo wir es für
selbstverständlich halten dass leute mit
25 erst die lebensentscheidung treffen
in welche richtung sie sich bewegen
jeder der unterrichtet jeder der mit mit
jugendlichen arbeitet weiß talente
zeichnen sich ab und je früher diese
talente gefördert werden desto besser
nochmal wer auf die hauptschule geht das
war die ursprüngliche idee ist ja nicht
dümmer und aber auch nicht automatisch
intelligente als der der aufs gymnasium
geht sondern hat andere talente die dort
gezielter gefördert werden als auf dem
gymnasium
ich glaube genau diese diskussion
braucht es stärker denn je dass wir
unsere kinder wieder nach talenten
fähigkeiten und fertigkeiten fördern
fordern und auch in den entscheidungs
raum bieten für das was sie im leben
machen können und dass wir auch
aufzeigen das handwerk ehrlicherweise
kann ich etwas studieren aber mit dem
handwerk habe ich in goldenem boden weil
ich ja stück weit mein eigenes
unternehmen gründen kann und aktuell in
der jetzigen situation bei dem enormen
handwerker mangel unglaubliche
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten habe also ich
glaube dass diese alte these dieses
akademie sieren also entweder der
akademiker oder das handwerk ein ende
finden muss sondern vielmehr wieder nach
den fähigkeiten und fertigkeiten unsere
kinder gefördert und gefordert werden
müssen und das beginnt aus meiner sicht
schon bei der früh mint bildung
ehrlicher er war ja denn das ist aus
meiner sicht der schlüssel dazu dass
eben kinder die vielleicht aus
elternhäusern kommen wo sie keinen bezug
dazu haben den bezug finden und für sich
den weg wenn über die schulbildung reden
wir später nach